let's take our real last call now 617
830 4750 you are the actual last caller
today what's your name and where you
calling from [ __ ] my name is really
i'm calling from buffalo wyoming all
right what can we do for you today first
call ever from wyoming i think i'm so
long time canada show uh but I had a
good question i want to post you please
on i was wondering what you think the
public reaction would be if they on
Hillary Clinton order when they like
four o'clock college and Donald Trump
were to win the popular vote well I
think it would be a recipe for
obstructionism it would be a recipe for
Trump to claim that it was rigged it
would be probably an inducement for
violence by Trump supporters and uh I
think it would expose significant
hypocrisy compared to in two thousand
when Al Gore won the popular vote but
lost the electoral vote uh I really find
it a very unlikely scenario I I don't
think that's going to happen the way
things are looking but I think that it
would open up a can of worms that would
have real-world repercussions if that
were to happen if Hillary Clinton were
to win electoral II but lose the popular
vote to trump okay sir if I thought all
in of itself um thank you all right my
pleasure great to hear from Wyoming
there and we will all hope that does not
happen really yeah thank you okay thank
you for the call really really
appreciate it we will take calls again
next week post-election who will be the
president-elect when we speak next week
or will something so insane happen that
there is no president-elect when we take
calls next week we'll see